after meeting the adult andy barkley
during the post-credits scene of the
last movie we're now introduced to his
snowy cabin which gives us little clues
about how his character developed in the
14-year absence after child's play 3.
it's obvious that he made himself a
hunter and sports an impressive
collection of firearms between that and
this framed sweater from kent academy
the military school that he attended as
a teen it's safe to say that his time at
the school had a profound effect on him
the latin text at the bottom of the
garment says nunclum non-peritus which
translates to never unprepared a perfect
description of andy if i ever saw one
behind this frame is a secret save we
only see him punch in part of the
combination if we assume that each
number on the keypad has a unique touch
tone then we can use sound to figure out
what the full combination is one one
zero zero one one which is binary for
the number three kent academy is the
setting of child's play 3 and cult of
chucky is the first sequel to andy's
story in child's play 3 26 years in the
making it's probably also no coincidence
that the spare good guy doll that andy
keeps has short hair this not only helps
andy differentiate his doll from the
others but might also be a nod to the
fact that he and the other cadets were
forced to maintain short hair at the
academy additionally during one bizarre
dream scene nika sees this image of
chucky flash before her eyes this is
chucky from child's play 3. nico was not
there for child's play 3 so this has to
be for us the audience to learn how one
character in this movie might have been
connected to the main character from the
chucky tv series stick around to the end
of this video
[Applause]
[Music]
guess what you've been involuntarily
committed to another episode of things
you missed the only way to get out of it
is if you need to watch the previous
episodes as of posting i've covered
every chucky movie cult of chucky came
on the heels of the darker more serious
curse of chucky but despite having a
similar visual style and bringing back
curse's protagonist cult kind of falls
back into the old ways of facetious
jokes and overt references through the
good and the bad i'll be here to guide
you through some of the things you may
have missed so let us get in to some of
the things you may have missed
[Music]
the film opens with andy on a date and
it definitely feels like a conscious
choice that he's chosen a redhead woman
after living a life of ptsd from this
red-headed doll it's possible that nika
who was also tortured by chucky befell
the same fate based on this off-color
joke from her fellow inmate malcolm you
still have a thing for redheads however
it's not long into the date that andy
realizes she's aware of his tumultuous
past you googled me oh so google does
exist in this world i only bring it up
because they went to extreme lengths
than the last movie to specify that the
search engine that nika uses is called
internet search and perhaps stranger
still later in this movie we find out
that andy uploads content on the famous
social media site video the dates
doesn't work out so andy finds himself
home and cracking open a drink from the
fridge the brand of choice is called
bladies perhaps a reference to chucky's
favorite weapon his trusty blade yeah
andy's on that beer and mayonnaise diet
right now andy's safe contains a
captured chucky head who despite his
situation tries to bite andy prompting
him to ask you want to play which is one
of the phrases that the original good
guy doll says in the original movie hey
wanna play this is not the only time
that cult of chucky echoes lions from
the past during the group therapy
session at the psychiatric hospital we
hear one of the patients say chucky did
it a line that andy learned not to say a
long time ago chucky did it you did it
chucky
yeah i did so he admits it of course
this wouldn't be a post-scream chucky
movie if there weren't some kind of
franchise callback every five minutes or
so let's make sure we've got them all
covered anyone mind if we start with
child's play one oh you do mind well too
bad at the beginning we see nika
receiving some kind of shock therapy
okay i don't even know if that's
supposed to be a callback but it's just
nice to see that they invented a shock
therapy device that doesn't kill you
since uh that unfortunate dr ardmore
incident in the first movie after the
treatment one of the doctors pricks nico
with a needle and says see the waist
down she's a pincushion another form of
paint cushion is a voodoo doll perhaps a
reference to the fact that charles lee
ray obtained the power to supernaturally
possess a doll using the art of voodoo
in the first movie later on when chucky
has infiltrated the hospital he finds
himself alone with one of the patients
claire who's strapped down to a hospital
bed the way chuckie scurries around her
before taking her out is very similar to
how he circles mike norris's crashed car
in the original when i covered that
first film on things you missed i talked
about how i found this good guy doll
mascot to be way creepier than the
actual chucky doll
look at this thing imagine this chasing
after you in a dark alley would have
been way better well i kind of got my
wish in colts during nika's dream
hallucination scene although instead of
a dark alley it's a bright hallway but
seeing this giant chucky is probably my
favorite part of this movie also take a
closer look at the reflection in the
giant chucky's knife this is the human
form of charles lee ray who we've seen
in the original movie and in the
flashbacks during curse of chucky
finally the story and cult ends with
andy voluntarily entering the asylum to
try to save nika but he ends up locked
in solitary confinement as a result this
isn't the first time he's been here as
way back in child's play he was locked
up in a children's mental facility and
the way he slides into a sitting
position against the wall mimics the
exact response that he had back then but
that's just the child's play one
references we've still got to talk about
all the secrets linking colts to the
rest of the franchise the hidden text on
these tombstones and the rest of the
things you
[Music]
missed when the chucky cult has expanded
to three different dolls they start to
interact with each other and share their
love of being a serial criminal chucky
refers to this as his job which i don't
fully understand because he's not
getting paid for it as far as i can tell
and i love my job especially the look on
my victim's face when they realize in
that final moment that it's all really
happening
a children's toy is actually beating
them to death with a yardstick or
setting them on fire eviscerating them
all actual examples we've seen a couple
of these the yardstick is from child's
play too where chucky gives andy's
schoolteacher a little after school
punishment the fire comes from bride of
chucky where we see him set a cop car in
blaze i don't really know who he
eviscerated it could be an off-screen
death there are a lot of other bride of
chucky references though for example
when claire is restrained on the
hospital bed chucky uses an oxygen tank
to shatter the glass ceiling above her
and it is actually the falling glass
shards that do her in this is
effectively the same kill as the one
that tiffany committed at the honeymoon
suite motel in niagara falls where she
throws a champagne bottle at a mirror on
the seal the main concept of colts
revolves around chucky's new ability to
inhabit more than one body at once he
claims the spell comes from
voodoofordummies.com the online version
of the spell book that tiffany uses in
bride at one point we see three chucky
dolls all possessed by charles lee ray's
soul at the same time and when nurse
carlos comes into the room and sees
what's going on all of their heads turn
simultaneously to face him the
short-haired chucky's head does a 180
degree spin something that we saw in
bride and nearly every entry since
there's another bride reference not long
after when tiff arrives and slits the
throat of a cop from behind this one
might actually just be a security guard
i'm not really sure but this is the
third time that we've seen her do this
some things never change though a true
classic never goes out of style the one
movie that doesn't get a lot of love and
cult thankfully is seed when i talked
about seed i mentioned how the opening
is very similar to the opening of
halloween a little bit of chucky paying
homage to his slasher forefather cult
also has a beginning that's similar to
halloween just for the fact that very
early on we see a patient transfer
several halloween movies have a patient
transfer at the beginning in particular
halloween 4 begins with michael myers
being moved to a lower security hospital
which is exactly what we see happening
to nika when we first see her character
in cult finally we have the last movie
curse of chucky there's not much in
terms of things you might have missed
since come on this was only one movie
ago however when we first see nika in
the cafeteria at harry gate hospital the
scene opens with a top-down shot on this
bowl it's got to be a callback to the
dinner scene from curse which used the
same camera angle and left the audience
to guess whose meal was poisoned in
addition to its connections to chucky
movies of past there also seem to be
links to the future that's right i'm
talking about the chucky series season
one but i'm going to come back to that
later in this video first i want to take
a closer look at the opening title
sequence because we haven't done that
yet we are shown various headlines
recapping the events of curse if you
look at the author of this one it says
ladonna kettlebono this is probably a
family member of jeremy bomb who's
listed in the movie's credits as the
animator of the main title sequence the
other one is by surya cassidy i'm
guessing if you switch those words
around to say cassidy surya you would
have the wife of the title designer
martin surya the hospital has its own
graveyard on sites and there are a bunch
more crew reference easter eggs
including costume designer patricia j
henderson property master mark stratton
assistant production coordinator aaron
graham assistant set decorator robert
kessler accounting clerk heather wiebe
payroll accountant tracy phillips first
assistant director douglas mitchell
accounting clerk tammy gibson and art
department coordinator donna jenkins
yeah there's always a lot of crew
reference easter eggs when we're dealing
with gravestones and memorials i learned
that from my final destination videos
now if you've seen my videos on bride
and seed you know that that's when
chucky was very inspired by the scream
franchise and its medicine tendencies i
explained how each of those movies does
its own take on a classic horror film
with bride of chucky obviously doing
bride of frankenstein and cedar chucky
doing alfred hitchcock's psycho here in
cult of chucky one of the mental
patients madeline believes that the
chucky doll is her baby during an
episode of schizophrenia i'm your friend
to the end you know chucky a boy's best
friend is his mother if you've seen
psycho you probably recognize that line
well a boy's best friend is his mother
but it would be a different movie that
served as kind of the base movie for
cult of chucky only this time it
wouldn't be a horror movie early on nika
receives a pack of juicy fruit gum from
this nurse this brings to mind a
well-known scene from the 1975 film one
flew over the cuckoo's nest where the
main character mick murphy offers his
seemingly mute inmate some juicy fruit
which leads to him discovering that he
was faking it he actually can hear and
speak nika's situation at harry gate is
kind of similar only she's not really
faking it she was actually forced to
believe that she's crazy because nobody
else will believe that chucky is alive
the character madeline also tries to
snuff chucky out with a pillow at one
point which is something that also
happens in one flew over the cuckoo's
nest i'm not going to spoil it if those
two scenes aren't enough proof that
harrogate is based on the hospital from
one flue chucky basically calls it out
when he shows up there jesus
believe it or not that is not the most
obvious reference in the movie you sound
like hannibal lecter i can't believe
they canceled that show i guess the
story there is that the creator of
child's play in chucky don mancini
worked on the hannibal tv series during
its final season so he was upset when
the show got cancelled however i guess
that his short time on that show ended
up inspiring him to bring chucky to the
small screen so maybe it all worked out
in the end speaking of which as dr foley
and nurse carlos are treating one of the
patients they engage in a little small
talk which contains an interesting and
potentially significant detail
one interesting aspect of cult of chucky
is the fact that the killer dolls are
not the only bad guys in this film
there's also the abusive psychiatrist dr
foley who hypnotizes nika so that she
cannot remember their sessions during
one of these sessions you can spot
chucky's shoes peeking out from behind a
curtain in the background as a little
clue that the possessed good guy doll
would be intervening before long it's
not until later in the movie that we
learn chucky can inhabit multiple bodies
but there's a clue in madeleine's room
she has drawn many sketches of the
chucky doll and one of them has eyes
with huge pupils which in the previous
films is what happens when chucky comes
to life meaning that madeleine has seen
this happen if you're paying close
attention to the calendar date of each
event you may have also known that there
has to be more than one chucky andy
figures it out before we as the audience
know i explained this in full detail in
my andy barkley horror history speaking
of andy he's on his way to the asylum to
try to save nika and the others and he
receives a strange call from
someone tiffany
jennifer
even i lose track she leaves a one-word
clue from chucky and andy is supposed to
know the meaning of it the word is
disembowel andy's plan is to hide his
gun inside the short-haired chucky to
get it into harrogate and then
disembowel him to get it back once
inside however chucky and tiffany don't
know that so what's the deal here this
part has always confused me the best
sense that i can make of it is that
chucky was threatening andy basically
just implying that he plans to
disembowel him and it's just an ironic
coincidence that andy turns the tables
on him if anyone has a better
explanation let me know also when he
does break open the chucky doll we can
see all the brains and guts and stuff
even though this chucky doll has only
been alive for like under an hour it
seems like the amount of time it takes
for chucky to turn human can be really
inconsistent for reference in child's
play too it takes about 48 hours for
chucky to turn human after being
reincarnated but in curse he doesn't
turn human for the entire movie but
let's get back on topic dr foley he's
about to give some kind of treatment to
claire when he says this
how's jake
the next chucky installment would be the
chucky tv series where a character named
jake wheeler loses both of his parents
my first thought is that carlos somehow
knows jake wheeler and dr foley is
asking how jake is holding up after the
death of his father however after
spending all day trying to piece
together the timeline using the new
information from season one i think
maybe it's possible that he was asking
about jake's mother who would have died
two years before colt in 2015. if you're
confused at all about the chucky
timeline watch this video where i
explain all of it of course another
possibility is that dr foley is asking
about a different person named jake and
i agree that is the easy explanation but
it doesn't account for this part where
chucky knocks out dr foley and tries to
get nika to finish him off with the
bottle i'm not a killer this is part of
a different voodoo ritual where chucky's
aim is to corrupt an innocent to get
them to kill in other words jake wheeler
wasn't the first one he tried to corrupt
it was actually nika at the very least
this proves that don mancini kind of
knew what was going to happen in season
one at the time that he made calls so
it's not out of the question that dr
foley actually was asking carlos about
our jake also the actor that plays dr
foley is michael theriault he also plays
lexi's dad nathan cross in the tv series
it's definitely a different character so
maybe the character he plays in the
series is a relative of dr foley which
would further connect to these two
communities but that's just speculation
however since chucky is unable to get
nika to kill for him he does the next
best thing and takes over her body and
this obviously leads into the events of
season 1 but first we got to talk about
that post-credits scene for the first
time since child's play 2 we see andy's
former foster sister kyle and when she
appears she's wearing the same hat and
outfit that we saw her hand when she
first appeared in that movie chucky and
tiffany do leave the hospital but
he'll be back he always comes back
and so will i in the next chucky episode
of things you missed where i'll be
covering season 1 of the chucky tv
series remember to subscribe to cz's
world for new horrors every week ring
the death bell and select all
notifications and i will see you in the
next one assuming we both survived
[Music]
you